là on va voir un ancien patient qui est
déjà venu il regardait les écrans depuis
l'âge de 6,9 mois à peu près à raison de
7 heures par jour on va voir s'il
sevrage a été efficace
[Applaudissements]
petit garçon avec beaucoup les écrous où
est-ce que vous en êtes dites-moi bah
c'est toujours compliqué mais en fait le
mieux il a fait quand même des progrès
par rapport à ce que je me souviens là
il parle beaucoup on comprend beaucoup
mieux quand il parle là on avait pas
trop le choix vu qu'il va à l'école
bientôt il faut qu'il en parler vite on
va dire mais il faut consulter pour voir
comment ça va se passer j'ai vu les
enfants comme votre petit garçon quand
on faisait un sevrage total vraiment
total et c'est difficile moi je suis
maman de 5 enfants donc je sais bien de
quoi je parle c'est difficile quand on
fait un sevrage total les enfants ils
recommencent à parler beaucoup mieux on
est devant un problème de santé publique
important avec des enfants qui vont pas
bien et qui se retrouvent collés à
l'écran et l'écran empêche
développement du langage empêche le
développement des apprentissages de
l'enfant dès 2017 j'ai commencé à
m'informer et je me suis rendu compte
que les enfants étaient des heures dans
les écrans que quand il y avait des
retards de langage de devimposer la
question de la place de l'écran et très
souvent effectivement l'enfant depuis
l'âge de 3 mois 9 mois regarder les
écrans beaucoup trop et du coup rentrait
pas dans le langage aux États-Unis on
dit pas d'écran avant 2 ans en France on
dit pas avant de trois ans moi je dis je
trouve que c'est un compromis entre les
deux pas d'écran tant que votre enfant
ne sait pas parler est-ce que vous êtes
venu me voir l'école
[Applaudissements]
c'est au moins plus de 6 à 12 mois de
temps où on est inadapté par rapport aux
produits ou une addiction sans substance
comme elle est grand et donc ces enfants
ça fait largement plus parce qu'ils ont
tous au moins plus d'un an voire plus de
2 ans pour certains de temps d'écran
inadapté pourquoi addiction parce que il
ne pense qu'à ça parce qu'ils ont plus
parce que la seule chose qui leur fait
plaisir c'est ça parce que quand on leur
enlève ça entraîne des situations de
stress de colère de frustration
ingérable à tel point qu'on leur redonne
donc tous ces processus là c'est les
processus de l'addiction au début on
s'est dit bon ça calme un peu on a le
temps de faire ce qu'on ce qu'on peut
mais bon après voilà les conséquences
sont là c'est pas une bonne organiser
tous ces trois enfants pour faire le
ménage pour faire à manger donc je t'ai
dit là il regarde la télé tout le monde
a assis on peut faire ce qu'on peut
et puis après on trouve ça comme une
solution quand vous craquez vous ne
mettiez pas ce qu'il aime il faut les
mettre autre chose des choses qui vont
doucement T'choupi trop trop il va pas
aimer parce que ça va trop doucement par
rapport à patrouille et tout ça qui va
beaucoup trop vite et qui fait exprès
pour que son cerveau ne s'arrête pas de
regarder les choses lent ça fait moins
de mal allez courage au revoir mon chat
la vie c'est pas simple parce que la vie
elle s'arrête pas à la semaine et à
l'école il faudrait que le week-end
cette maman toute seule puis c'était des
ça ça arrive très souvent que maman se
retrouve toute seule à élever des
enfants la société n'est pas assez
séparent seul société essaie de faire
plein de choses mais pas suffisamment
dans ça parce que la prévention n'est
pas bien faite et surtout actuellement
on ne peut pas aider correctement les
familles par exemple des enfants qui ne
vont pas en crèche des mamans qui ne
travaillent pas on leur dit il y a pas
de place et donc la maman si elle est en
incapacité de garder son enfant
autrement qu'avec l'écran elle est seule
depuis 2018 noter dans le carré de santé
que les écrans étaient mauvais pour les
enfants de moins de 3 ans il y a que 10%
des parents qui le font il est parti en
vacances au mois de février et ça a été
une catastrophe de venir en finale et
les la seule chose qui le calmaient
c'était les écrans c'est vraiment
scroller
même quand on a du 3 ans aujourd'hui
c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui il
faut commencer très tôt quand vous
attendez un bébé les parents qui
attendent là un enfant et ben dès la
grossesse il faut se poser la question
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec notre
téléphone pour le bébé sera là on se dit
au revoir